مشاهدينا ماء الزهق جديد يواجه تطبيق تيك
توك في الولايات المتحده ليعود بذلك
التطبيق الصيني مره اخرى الى قفص
الاتهامات بالتجسس ومعها ترتفع وتيره
المحاوف الامريكيه من هذا التطبيق هذه
المخاوف دفعتها سنه الجمهوري ماركو روبيو
للكشف عن تشريع مدعوم من اعضاء الحزبين
الجمهوري والديمقراطي لحضر تطبيق التواصل
الاجتماعي الصيني الشهير تيك توك تشريع
يزيد الضغط على شركه باي دانس المالكه
للتطبيق مخاوف امريكيه من امكانيه استخدام
التطبيق في التجسس على الامريكيين هذا
المشروع الجديد ياتي والمدعون من اعضاء في
الحزبين كما ذكرنا بعد ان شاركت كل من
اداره الرئيس الامريكي الحالي جوبايدن
والسابق دونالد ترامب ما خوف بشان التطبيق
ومخاطره الامنيه الاجراءات الامريكيه لن
تقصر على تطبيق تيك توك فقط بل ستشمل ايضا
تطبيقات صينيه اخرى للتواصل الاجتماعي
وحتى التطبيقات الروسيه لن تفلت من
التشريع الامريكي هذا عنا وفقا لاكسيوس
وقد ساعدت عدد من الولايات المتحده بما في
ذلك يوتا وماريلاند وتكسس بالفعل الى حضر
استخدام همم تيك توك في الوكالات الحكوميه
طبعا عن رده فعل تيك توك قال متحدث باسم
تيك توك في بيان انه بدلا من تشجيع
الاداره على استكمال مراجعتها ذات الصله
بالامن القومي لتيك توك قرر بعض اعضاء
الكونجرس الضغط من اجل حضر التطبيق
[موسيقى]